not here again oh [__]
[Music]
this is that this is death wish
in the way you wearing a glow
[Music]
you tell you mama
I get you home oh [__] you know no [__]
around this is doctor beliefs the book
is working breathe [__]
[Music]
are you kidding me or what [__]
Wednesday night we're here we're back
we think you're dealing with some
[__] novice I'm gonna take the night
off there's a surgery you got to shoot
me in the foot for me to [__] take
off of you guys as a matter of fact I
told you this morning
I'm this [__] but we're here with
throwing bong hits on oxycottons tonight
either you're in or Yahoo and the
stamina here oh yeah I know what the
[__] to tell you but I did Wilfong hit
an oxycontin
[Music]
a fact [__] how to adjust the pond I
put some fresh spring water in this
[__]
[Music]
ready Foley's bond hit this weed is
[__] tremendous balloon cookies from
perennial listen get jazzed down and
down
it's a sativa like a [__] high
[Music]
yeah there you go
it's Wednesday night [__] I
told you just as I got surgery didn't
but pussyfoot around we'll go with deep
delay we got no edibles left taking the
night off
there's nothing anesthesia I got the
oxycontin Larry's happy closing a reef I
got everything to be tied down with the
Stars at that please drink some water
you gonna be fine you'll see
I still love you so I can't let you go
what's up people get that bum out get
that pipe I don't give a [__] if you
shoot dope tonight you're lucky [__]
thanks you like their teeth you
understand me I still got blood coming
out of my nose a little bit I blew a
coke rap last night out of my head ball
yeah it's a beautiful [__] thing I'm
breathing again tell the sleep we'll
have to sleep at Unity if you look close
you can see the stitches right there
it's a [__] nightmare don't even look
cuz I'm about to pass out I gotta go fry
they seem to take the stitches out but
that was that Lee you're ready for
another bucket
[Music]
you get anxiety and you break up into a
short [__] sweat science
well while leave recovers you were
nagging do a couple bong hits you know
go for the baddest an acapella as they
say in [__] jet town fill our fresca
you know breakfast to eat outside yeah
Oh fresca
let's see that side all freshmen [__]
out of my face
dreading my pork chops breathin [__]
dirty feet pollution and [__] good
man
you get [__] dirty just walking
around you take a shower at 6:30 that's
dirt the tug an even playing saying the
pollution to the [__] and the heat
comes off the ground
[Music]
oh [__] this is the deep one here Todd
you got two tremendous tweets in it I
went back and water hate to the [__]
blue cookies and I got King Henry the
[__] eighteenth or some [__] it don't
really matter and a little bit about
cakes I don't want [__] King that's
all you need to know you ready let's do
this [__] these are the big the [__]
I'm not sure what's happening but I'm
gonna need a lung transplant type of
[__] that builds character it's a
beautiful thing this is toughest [__]
man speaking from the tuna to the
Schnoodle this [__] I don't give
a [__] we got a beat that's true
[Music]
I look like [__] Martin Sheen but I
come on rewarding apocalypse man who
does bong hits like that beaten nobody
this is will where he no drama you don't
see no poster of buds I'm gonna die here
with Denny long hair will this pose out
like [__] dabs I don't mean that [__]
right here the pipe of debt with the we
today with the jeweler debt loser gets
smoked a reefer with your [__] family
all [__] day I've been training bit
chilly yeah that's it
listen people I've been training I had
to surgery all I've been killing time is
for this [__] surgery that's it just
the whole week up and right making
little notes I'm gonna try to make this
special the best [__] special it
could be but it starts this [__] week
I was just trying to get rid of this
[__] metal after this I'm gonna do
trishal this we're gonna work it that's
it I gotta look good
I gotta feel good I got a [__]
daughter that you know needs me but
continue smoking reefer because you and
I we got no beefs we just hear the smoke
reefer together crack a couple jokes
listen to some [__] music see my
brother Lee do his thing
[Music]
sure this one talking about you
understand me balls in the translation I
tell you people that was a [__] Diaz
on the Santa Maria with Christopher
Columbus I tell you that with the pig
out brothers yeah sure
listen happy [__] you [__]
up since day one I'm gonna stop water I
put my uncle mr. stack that's right
[__]
I was my great-great grandfather was in
the Santa Maria beating up Indian
strangled William entire I can't claim
responsibility friendship lock the door
put out the lights
oh [__]
they won't be home tonight [__]
this would be a little bumpy just to get
the blood pool is the third one
I know no I just did a double no that's
okay Jimmy get this never turn down a
bomb and why is he so good under the
table cause you never turn down a bomb
he understand me he better come let me
fill up on that title to play the guitar
oh [__] here we go
they hold no quarter I could slip I
can't stall again I can't taste yet but
I didn't today I cleaned up my nose with
the [__] pool and water if the saline
solution and destroys it my dough's a
spit little waters out brother whatever
son what's up we will wait nothing let's
do the jump the jump just wanted him
plus that's how we don't see how was it
good one for you that's a training
it's a babymoon see nobody course oh my
god that's the go feet tonight to get
eyeballs that [__] might more fill
even get red number that [__]
mechanism broke the one the warranty
will even fix it you know you just get
too old that's what happens I smoked so
much refinery in that windshield wiper
some eyes
I haven't teared up in years right oh
[__]
[Music]
there's a beautiful [__] sativa people
you know unless most the team is nothing
advocate as a team because they don't
get me nothin like that Johnny with Jack
Herrera that [__] don't do that uncle
Joey but this [__] cookies it's a hybrid
Santino with the [__] lien on remove
all the [__] cookies people and I'm
Tania you guys don't know what you're
missing if you live in the valley or if
you live in Hollywood I tell you what
when I put a stamp on weed this [__]
killed me yesterday and they got my
appetite going after the surgery and
then another week that didn't get my
appetite going this got my [__] together
you understand me so if you're looking
for something that put a little pep in
your step
and if they take you for the next level
and listen to me it will take you to the
next level so you know we love you - I
missed you [__] the surgery
went well I don't know like I said they
gotta take the stitches out on Friday
we'll pop the bottle on the podcast I'll
see you guys in tempers oh [__] no let's
play this out this is great out don't
kick it down wait your [__] ball
please let me do another bomb
[Music]
you know some people bombs you Minister
duty this is a view right here listen
this [__] bomb kill you
this is a kill somebody with a heart
condition comes in here don't run out of
here quicker than old Benjamin I just
knew I've had 30,000 bombs big ones
don't do it there's a pond that's a
little bigger than this maybe three or
four inches that's not a bad one but the
big ones over-exaggerated you can't get
all the smoke anyway unless I got
[__] long moves it's just decoration
for people who made a [__] bad
judgment call this is the power kicker
right here two three inches
it looks like a black [__] only white
you say the same
oh [__] this is a thick [__] piece of
machinery you can use it as a weapon
take this out so I have this right here
there's a weapon dog you had a
[__] the head with this right
here
diesel six to seven stitches if he Sue's
you 30,000 a stitch 210 [__] that's your
insurance companies I'm saying I got
Geico [__] you got full already but you
can't wear stereo [__]
that's like a [__] you know what you
expect the genie the [__] Papa what
listen let first heard this sound in 75
when I heard this song I thought I was
gonna jump out the window
I just couldn't push the air conditioner
if I could push the air condition I
would be I'd be hit with a flat head
right there and one I bought this place
from two people stoned to the gills
welcome back [__] thank you for
having me back uncle Joey we missed you
we missed me look at me
why you guys are [__] around [__]
around over the years leaves grown to be
a soldier baby sweating profusely to the
level I took you for guys if I have a
cigarette right movement turn out that
cigarette you know I've never tried that
what is it higher
[Music]
there's nothing better professionals
know what I'm talking about and waking
up at the border blast of the cigarette
and then blast in the [__] joint
then blast another cigarette in a cup of
coffee who's better you leave the house
which [__] fire coming out again like
the Batmobile some cigarettes isn't
coffee the moon would have good food
foods bang
[Music]
stall to the gills people open you do
the same this is the [__] salvation
hooray it's pity those powers go away
[__] I love you guys we're gonna be
on YouTube I hope you go to on no
YouTube face leave the [__]
sensational job you know we just moved I
will tell you one thing I'm not going to
- broke up door then my apologies to
Nashville I'm gonna change the date cuz
I got invited to open up the weekend and
I bought fast so I'm doing the dates in
West Palm Beach
Tampa Atlanta and Indianapolis
you guys heard it right here from bad
flavor you have [__] uncle Joey
I'm hosting that developers like Segura
and [__] Sebastian don't quote me
I'll just give you what I heard on the
street all right they quality they put
me it's August 25th we six 27 - 28
I'll tell you people don't have to tell
ya Joey you know and that's a concept is
my back I feel a little [__] up but we
got to do the show
I'll talk about on the podcast see you
tech better stay black [__]